so listen Ted the first question is
always the obvious one but essential so
how did this come about and what exactly
was it that inspired you to move forward
with this project
um before I answer I just want to say
stepping up on the stage I feel a little
bit like Gustavo stepping onto the
philharmony hall in Burlington it's like
in Berlin rather it's sort of like being
at the center of the world yeah
[Laughter]
um
I am
the film started as a lot of films in
Los Angeles start over breakfast in a at
a Jewish delicatessen in the valley
I am I had just finished
um a film called betting on zero which
followed a billionaire hedge fund
manager and a Latino activist as they
were trying to expose Herbalife as a
global international fraud
and was looking for a change of pace and
one of the producers of the film Howard
bragman over breakfast in the valley
um asked me if I thought Gustavo dudamel
would make a good subject for a
documentary and it didn't take me very
long at all to say yes I had been a
classical musician as a kid
um
I've been living in Los Angeles
and going to the Philharmonic since long
before Gustavo arrived and the idea of
pivoting to make a film about a man who
was as brilliant as anyone I knew of at
bringing art and Beauty into the world
as opposed to exposing the problems the
world seemed like a very refreshing
change and I said yes and was introduced
to Gustavo and his management team and
over the course of the summer and a
couple conversations with Gustavo in the
fall of 2016 we quickly arrived at a at
a plan so how were those first first
conversations and what was your first
impression of of the maestro
well
um the first impression is was not so
terribly different from I I think the
one that you may have of him from the
film which is that he is as articulate
about aesthetic matters as anyone I've
ever encountered
um that he's quite open and accessible
and endlessly Charming
and um to my great Good Fortune he was
very creatively agreeable to the
approach that we that we were talking
about which at that time was uh uh a
film that would explore
the art of conducting and the work of
bringing uh orchestral music into the
world I wanted to get inside the
imagination of a conductor it's a
strange place to be I mean a man is
looking at a Stave with notes on a page
a kind of written language that for most
of us is really incomprehensible and
from that formulates an interpretation
entirely in his imagination and then
somehow communicates that to a hundred
plus musicians over the course of a
series of rehearsals that is kind of a
dialogue without words
and then they take that and bring it to
an audience that's moved enough to cry
or leap to their feet I mean it's a
fascinating process and um and I thought
that would be exciting to bring to life
and and also to bring to life who he was
and what made him tick and he liked the
idea
so when you start a documentary
and I asked this about documenting
filmmakers all the time what were your
initial goals and how did your goals
change but in your case
your initial goals were sidetracked by a
very big change that was thrust upon you
I mean talk about the motherload of
changes so the question is as those
changes were thrust upon you and upon uh
Maestro did them out
um what were the conversations you had
for that shift and
and was was Gustavo like on board with
that
um
yes ultimately I mean you see he you
know he's with us all the way
um uh
we were in a very strange position the
film had not not intended to put the
problems of Venezuela front and center
you know we we weren't going to
completely ignore them but they were
essentially something that we thought
was a sort of backdrop to his work with
the orchestra
both the LA fill and the and the bully
bars but the day after that tour ended
Venezuela erupted into the hundred days
of protests that you see in the film
violent protests and um
and Gustavo who had been sort of
resolutely
um uh uh uh standing aside from
commenting on the issues of of what was
happening at his home was put in the
position you see in the film where he
felt he had to speak out over a series
of different occasions in that summer of
2017.
and
um
as the film demonstrates
the orchestra that he led had its tour
canceled and then players began to leave
and so Our intention which had been to
return to Venezuela two or three more
times at least to deepen our
understanding of his work with the
orchestra and where he came from and how
they operated became impossible um
because he wasn't going back
and so
we there was no way we could continue to
make that kind of film and we weren't in
a position and we discussed this with
Gustavo or we could really ignore
um what had happened and sort of Allied
or skip over the problems of Venezuela
and just make a movie about him and
music it it just wouldn't it would have
been irresponsible and and really blind
so the question then became
what's the story we're now telling and
what do we film and initially we thought
we were going to be telling a reunion
story a story of a man separated from
his orchestra trying to bring them back
together
and to give you an idea of just how
intent we were on that when we went to
Mexico City to film what you see in in
the finished documentary as a as a sort
of celebration of Youth music making and
these wonderful performances of the
Dvorak
we brought a Bare Bones crew and had
absolutely no intention of filming any
music we were just interested in what
was happening between him and the bully
bars and the story of them getting back
together and a lot of those
conversations were too sensitive for us
to film which was frustrating and
disappointing and we kept waiting and
waiting for something to happen and
thankfully
um
the producer of the film Nick Payne and
and Buddy Squires or cinematographer
said Ted were here we might as well
shoot something I said but damn we have
enough music we don't need any more
music why don't we just do something
let's shoot the kids and shoot the kids
and so we found those kids and that
music and as it turned out when we got
to the editing room to really pull the
thing together it became clear that it
wasn't a reunion story we were filming
it was a story about him keeping a
Brave's dream alive
you know you went into this film with
the with the prospect of of doing
something inspirational uh enlightening
about an artist and an art and music and
it turned into something that you you
had already uh been experienced with
especially when it came to to uh Darfur
you know and Sudan so
um so your film star four now so how did
filming in Sudan back in
2007 or so sort of prepare you for what
ultimately was going on in Venezuela
with your crew
um well on a basic level
um I was
sensitized to the plight of human beings
whose country is in profound distress
and to both
the the pressures they're under the
anguish that they're experiencing the
limitations they have on what they can
say and do
and the Peril they're in so
um
we as a crew didn't arrive in Venezuela
uh sort of thinking things were just
going to be hunky-dory and we'd be
filming rehearsals and we're mindful of
all that which was important we're also
mindful that we were entering at that
time a a dangerous place and had to
manage
the risks that the crew was exposed to
you don't feel it in that footage from
Caracas but
um at the time
um it was it was one of the most
dangerous cities on the planet and the
big risk uh that we were concerned about
was was kidnapping there was a very very
high rate of kidnapping and
and
um and domestically and and
internationally in other words local
residents as well as um as well as
foreigners were being kidnapped and so
we had to operate with a a pretty
substantial security detail about four
times what I worked with in Sudan
so what were some of the
ethical challenges that you were faced
with uh and the crew and Gustavo during
that time
um I can't really speak to the ethical
challenge Gustavo was facing um but um
as a
as a as a production team one of the
things you're balancing whenever you're
in production is your desire to bring a
compelling story to the screen that in
this case we weren't trying to expose
anything of our characters we were
trying to bring their lives to life
we're to try to do that in a responsible
way that doesn't put anyone in any sort
of danger physical or political or you
know social Danger
and so those were challenges that we you
know navigated and did so in a very
direct way you know in in Sudan by
working with the government by working
with security people and by working with
Al Systema who was effectively our host
but a second set of challenges arose
when we were you know when we were
releasing the film or not releasing the
film when we were when we were cutting
the film anticipating its release and
that had to do with
the effect of the story we were telling
um on the people involved in it when the
film emerged into the world and
um and you know
um there are times when you can
you can make those judgments with a fair
degree of confidence inside your own
Circle
um and then there are times when you
really need to turn to your subjects and
the institutions that they're connected
with to make sure that there's no undue
harm that's or unintended harm that's
going to come to the people the
institutions are involved so in our case
we we were we had a cut we were we were
out to festivals with with with a cut
um and about to you know go into final
mixing and color correct when we we got
a sense that that that cut of the film
was was gonna be be problematic should
it emerge in the world and we had to we
had to go back and
and make some changes and in the end
um they were they were for the good I
think the film was a better film a whole
of us involved in it Kate they editor
The Producers everyone feels like what
we came came up with was was a better
film but it was that concern of how it
would play and the effect of it in the
world that that led us to that well Ted
Braun Bravo on Vivo Maestro thank you
very much thank you everyone for joining
us at this Academy screening of Eva
Meister thank you so much everybody good
evening thank you all